the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay now over I've been giving out lot
of the muddy cards for a few of the
lectures and two or three questions came
up in those that I haven't addressed so
far right kind of calling them loose
ends and I'm going to pick up on a
couple of those today I think they'll
help you kind of consolidate the
knowledge around the quiz and so I'm
going to couple of loose ends there and
then I'm the lecture topic I started
last time which is making this
transition from thinking about angular
momentum of particles to using the full
angular momentum equations for rigid
bodies where we talk about mass moments
of inertia and products of inertia and
that's where we'll pick up there again
today because that's where we're going
for the next few lectures okay
let's pick up with a name first example
here this is this is on the topic of
basically finding equations of motion
and there's been a little confusion or
with people I didn't notice that it
would asked me again Oh what we could
what do you mean fine to meet solve etc
and so I'm going to go through a just a
real quick example skipping some of the
steps because this be my purpose is
emphasizing the steps not working out
all the details so finding equations of
motion where does it begin so really one
of the really important steps is this
determine the number of independent
coordinates you need because when you've
done that that tells you basically the
that's also the number it really starts
finding the number of degrees of freedom
should have put this in different order
degrees of freedom tells you the number
of independent coordinates you need so
this is one two and then three that
leads you to the number of equations of
motion that you need so this is a really
an important step secondly draw Freebody
diagrams
and third apply summation of forces
external vector equations gives you mass
times acceleration and summation of
torques gives you d h d t + this V cross
P term so this is just kind of the step
by step so let's apply it briefly we've
talked a lot about things on Hills so
here's a cart it's got wheels attached
by a chord to a second mass that's
sliding m1 m2 doesn't stretch the chord
in between and let's think of these
things as rigid bodies so how many
degrees of freedom how many possible
degrees of freedom to sort of the
maximum possible you have how many rigid
bodies - how many degrees of freedom two
rigid bodies possible six each so we're
6 times M plus 3 times and minus a
number of constraints is the number of
independent degrees of freedom this is
number of rigid bodies number of
particles so we have 6 times 2 3 times 0
minus the constraints so this one comes
up 12 minus the constraints you have to
figure out to get strains quickly we're
we're not going to allow rotation in any
of the three directions on either and
they're they're on carts they're big or
sliding they're not rolling any of that
so no rotation for three no rotation for
three or more that's minus six
so C equals minus six or C equals six
for rotation and then what else can we
say
there's no I'll like designate this the
y direction so we can talk about
directions here and I'll designate this
X in general no acceleration at all in
the Y in the Y direction right can't
move in the Y so that gives us one two
for each mass plus two more it's eight
constraints that we've come up with now
a ninth constraint is the fact that
these two are tied together and so if
you had just temporarily assigned a
coordinate here X 1 and another one here
X 2 that we know for a fact that X 1 has
got to be equal to X 2 and that gives
you yet one more constraint so that's 9
and let's so we might just stop there we
say ok that's a total of 9 so the number
of degrees of freedom 12 minus 9 is 3
and that applies you need three
equations of motion some confusion comes
you know if something is not consumed
you start with start rephrase that
we don't talk anything about the Z
direction I haven't described any
constraints in the Z direction if you're
if this is me in a car and I'm dragging
it sled down a hill or I'm in a vehicle
I'm dragging this sled down a hill I
don't know if you've ever been in a
vehicle on a trailer on an icy with a
trailer on an icy road in the wintertime
that's a dicey maneuver ok so going down
a hill with trying to put brakes on so
this thing could conceivably move in
this direction and you can either
constraint it to be that way to make the
problem simple or you can just say it's
possible so we have three equations of
motion of which
- for now the summation of the forces
external in the since I've got x and y
the Z must be this way in the
y-direction and we'll make it in Z
Direction this is coordinate system 1 so
this would be z1 or z2 some of the shin
the forces z1 is m1 Y Z 1 double dot but
I'm going to set that equal to 0 I just
know of no forces so this becomes a
trivial equation of motion and another
one summation of the forces on the
second mass this is on m2 in the Z 2
Direction is M 2 Z 2 double dot now set
that equal to zero also so what it boils
down to I had three degrees of freedom
two trivial equations of motion leaving
me with just one equation of motion
that's going to be meaningful yeah
and that would that mean that the rod
has to be high relief along the x-axis
so he asked the VEX one equals f2 does
that mean they both have to be along the
x-axis I'm assuming that so I really am
assuming this thing's going down the
hill I'm making a point about this Z
Direction thing because it's just a
subtlety that you have to decide on when
your figure when you're figuring out how
to actually analyze a situation if you
really were thinking about what happens
when our vehicles are going down a steep
icy Hill towing a trailer maybe put the
brakes on maybe not you could probably
say well unless I really have disaster
then we're not going to get a rollovers
and things like that but you could
imagine that it could it can get out of
the x-direction right it could start
sliding in the Z probably not going to
go anywhere on the Y that's still a good
assumption so this is about this is
about modeling and how complicated do
you make the modeling so you actually
have to make quite a few modeling
decisions when you go to do this and we
tend in class and examples tend to
really oversimplify problems so that we
can do them right so I've boiled this
down to where I'm going to end up with
one significant equation of motion okay
and that one's going to say that the
summation of the forces in the
x-direction and I'm just going to write
em X double dot here not putting down M
1 or M 2 because we're going to have to
go to Freebody diagrams to figure out
what we how to apply this so Freebody
diagrams first mess so this is M 1 here
and 1 gee a normal force no doubt a
friction force I'll call that F 1 and
the tension in the cord and I'm assuming
the tension is going to always be there
so if you again in a situation where the
trailer starts overtaking the car I mean
the Rope goes slack we're not going to
consider that one today okay so there's
your Freebody diagram for the first one
and we're going to need to break em G
into a couple of components we're going
to need the slope here and that
translates into an angle here so there's
our first Freebody diagram on our second
Freebody diagram second mass tension
normal force another m2 G and this one's
on wheels and we're going to assume that
consider this one frictionless so we
don't have any friction force holding it
back
so the reason I've kind of this seems
like you know I'm ridiculous a simple
problem but the point I want to make is
not the solution not the particular
problem but an issue that crops up how
many unknowns are there in this problem
well do you know in one immediately rn2
or the friction force or the tension or
for that matter the X double dot we're
looking for there's actually you start
off this problem with five unknowns but
only you're only looking to derive one
equation of motion so the fact that
we're looking for one equation of motion
doesn't say you don't have to deal with
several intermediate equations to get
there that's just part of the part of
the work okay so this is five unknowns
to start with n1 n2 f1 T and X double
dot now I'm not going to so that if
you'll find out that the summation of
the forces on Y and the y 1 on the first
mess this one this gives you in one
summation the forces in the y-direction
on m2 this one gives you n 2 directly
from this flows directly you know that
the friction force is mu and 1 C that's
a third equation so this gives you one
equation this gives you another equation
this gives you a third equation you have
five unknowns you need five equations so
there's three of them right off the top
so this leaves you've solved for those
this leaves T and X double dot to solve
for
so now the sum of the forces on mass 1
in the x-direction says m1 x double-dot
and the sum of the forces on the second
mass in the x-direction gives you m2 X
double dot and I if I if I was
explicitly haven't said this yet what
I've done is one of my requirements is
x1 equals x2 and I'm just going to call
them X both of these are exactly the
same both masses have to move with the
same motion as the assumption so that
means that x1 double dot equals x2
double dot equals X double dot
that's what I'm assuming when I write
them down these two equations okay I can
write those two equations one from each
Freebody diagram I've already eliminated
through the unknowns and now because I
have two equations each have T in them
essentially you eliminate T and solve
for X double dot and if you do that in
this problem you get your equation of
motion
eliminate tea solve for x1 double dot
look at this and just look at things
that doesn't make sense
this says the total mass times the
acceleration it's a system it's one
system mass times the acceleration of
the center of gravity of the system if
you will it's got to be equal to the
sums of the forces on it well it's got
m1 plus m2 G sine theta pulling it down
the hill and it has minus mu m1 G cosine
theta dragging it back up the hill and
that's the entire equation motion makes
sense but the the equation of motion the
thing you're looking for is the one that
ends up with this acceleration term in
it if you have multiple degrees of
freedom multiple coordinates if you have
let's say three significant equations of
motion the result they won't necessarily
be one in terms of each coordinate
they'll have the coordinates mixed in
them like we did that two mass system
with Springs the other day each equation
of motion had x1 and x2 in it they don't
necessarily separate they're coupled
through their coordinates this one it's
a one equation of motion for the system
therefore you have only one coordinate
but that's not generally true of
multiple degree of freedom systems
okay that should mean your method though
for a simple problem now let's do I want
to do a little more difficult problem
that involves rotation rotation right
this is prime I'm sure you've done this
problem in physics it's a classic
problem that people do a disc a pulley
really supporting two masses rotates
about this point which I'll call a here
beside some theta there's no snow slip
so theta it was going to be related to
movement X and I'm going to assign this
one a coordinate x1 going down this one
a coordinate x2 going up a little
foreknowledge here because you've worked
the problem show out I want to solve for
the motion of the system now again we
need to know the number of degrees of
freedom so it's the maximum possible
which is our six M plus 3n minus the
constraints and let's think about you
know how we want to model this again
this time I'm just going to model these
as particles doesn't matter how big they
are my problem really they only go up
and down so by modeling the particles
this is 6 times 0 plus 3 times 2 minus
constraints it's a 6 minus the
constraint so the issues really how many
constraints well we're going to require
x1 equal X 2 chords taught doesn't
stretch if this thing goes down that has
to go up exactly an equal amount okay
and that's one constraint okay and that
leaving a 6 minus 1 is 5 leaving us with
a lot of degrees of freedom here now
kind of back to the issue as making
before are there any constraints in the
I'll call it X Y Z directions here there
any constraints in the Y or Z directions
on either those masses no I'm too shown
any no tracks no guys know anything so
technically there are no additional
constraints in this problem but if
there's no forces in the Y X I guess why
this way and no forces in the Z I'm
going to end up with two trivial
equations of motion for this one one in
the Y one and the Z for this one one and
the y one and the Z so back to this
issue of there's a difference between
constraints and trivial equations of
motion we're going to for to reveal
equations of motion so I really again
I'm going to come down to one
significant equation of motion so I have
one constraint for trivial PLMS and one
significant equation of motion okay now
because I want to talk about rotation we
need to pick it we need to pick a
coordinate now I can pick I can either
let x1 equal x2 and just let it be to
some X a single coordinate or theta the
rotation I'm actually going to use X for
a second
but there's there's two obvious ways to
approach this problem one is to sum is
to draw Freebody diagrams of each of
these masses sum the forces on each and
how many if I do that how many unknowns
do I end up with we can start we can
draw the free here's the free body
diagram for mass one once it got on it
well it's m1 G what's the other what
else is acting on it here's the second
one
m2 G and tension acting on it so now we
can sum sum sum of the forces equals
mass times acceleration of each one and
the external forces are going to involve
T so you can end up with how many
unknowns how many unknowns one idea
write two equations and the forces in
the x-direction X double dot certain
unknown what else T sign up to I end up
with this other unknown so that means
I'm going to have to write two equations
are going to have to eliminate T going
to go through the same thing there so I
don't want to bother with that is there
another way to do this problem
so this is a problem where you can use
angular momentum and not have to deal
with T at all so let's set that problem
so you know that the sum of the torques
about that point a with respect to point
a it's going to be derivative and since
we're dealing with particles here of the
angular momentum with respect to I'll
just call it lower case H for particles
plus it's velocity of a with respect to
an inertial frame cross the linear
momentum with respect to an inertial
frame that's the full equation for some
of the torques what's velocity of a with
respect to O in this problem zero so
that's fortunately this is one of those
problems you can get rid of this
nuisance this difficult second term so
it's just torques is the time derivative
of the angular momentum so we need an
expression then for both the sum of the
torques with respect to a let's see what
would that be the ik so now the external
torques with respect to the I'll finish
my look a mere you
free body diagram so now what I really
want is a free body diagram of the whole
system so here's the whole system
treated as one thing you have a force
down m1g another force down m2g up here
you have some normal force up that's the
support of the pin they have tensions in
these but now this equation applies it
this equation applies to the system the
T's are internal to the system they are
irrelevant so I'm talking about this
whole thing treated as a system and I'm
going to compute the moments about point
a which is right there where that axle
is does n create a moment at the axle
nope but there m1 and m2 create times G
create moments sure okay
so I'm going to have positive out of the
board be positive moment positive
angular direction so the torque supplied
to the system are R cross T so you're
going to end up with I want to summarize
these and m1g and I didn't write the
radius on this problem but at some
radius capital R so the torques are m1g
are positive minus m2g R K hat direction
and that must be equal to the time
derivative of the angular momentum about
a now we need an expression for the
angular momentum with respect to a
angular momentum is in general this is a
it's R cross linear momentum right so
our for mass one with respect to a cross
the pump the momentum of that second
mass with respect to an inertial frame
and a and the inertial frame are the
same thing a fixed in the inertial frame
but in Mangalore momentum is always with
respect to the inertial frame plus the
second piece which is R
of m2 with respect to a crossed with p4
mass - with respect to some inertial
frame okay so I'm just going to give you
the results to this m1 plus m2 r x dot K
so X dot is this velocity R cross that
and mass times velocity is momentum so
they perpendicular radius to that is the
radius R so it's R X dot times M
shouldn't surprise you in the K hat
direction that's the total angular
momentum that comes from these two
particles with respect to a and taking
their time derivative these are constant
that's a constant this is not this is a
constant but it doesn't change direction
so this one pretty simple
now I can set equal the sum of the
external torques that do the time
derivative of the angular momentum just
to fulfill this expression and in so
doing I end up with a solution for x
double-dot m1 minus m2 m1 plus m2 times
G turns out the R goes away never had it
so one equation never had to mess with
tension this is a pretty nice direct way
of solving this problem this mission if
you solve for G here and you measure X
double dot this actually gives you an
experimental way of determining
acceleration and gravity and it's
actually what the what this thing was
used for a long time ago before they had
a lot of the measurement techniques and
things that we do today this is a way of
determining the acceleration of gravity
so these two masses are quite close
together this is this number is pretty
small you can you know however accurate
your timing device is okay now just to
mention it I neglected something this I
assume something that didn't even say it
what was it what would screw up this
measurement I'm trying to measure the
acceleration of gravity if I built this
apparatus how would I did I get a very
good measurement yeah pulley would have
to be massless I've made an assumption
about that right so how would you fix up
this equation to account for the bullet
yeah I just put in something and where
would that go into the problem how would
you account for the moment it's inertia
moment of inertia and the problem yeah
you just put it into H a so there's
going this expression for H would end up
with one more term that's going to look
like well when you take the time to root
if you're going to end up with another
piece over here some I about a theta
double dot and you're going to have to
relate theta double dot to X double dot
which you can because x equals R theta X
double dot R theta double dot and you
could fix that and you'd have a an
equation of motion but that means we
need to know about I about a which were
that's where we're going to get the for
the next at the end of this lecture and
for the next several lectures okay
that's that example and I've got two
more brief ones that I wanted to talk
about any last questions yeah okay
so why did I did I not take the tensions
into account
so I can write the equation of motion
for this thing as a complete system one
if the masses in the pulley are all same
thing and the summation it's a the
summation of the torques external
torques on that you're going to mount up
to taking into account the time rate of
change of the angular momentum of the
system now if I had didn't understand
that I could have blindly gone ahead and
put the T's in there right but they
would have been exactly equal and
opposite with respect to a and would
have cancelled out so either way if
you're not sure about that assumption
you could just put them in and they
would appear in the torque equation but
as a minus TR and a plus TR and they'd
cancel okay I want to make a move on to
a third example and this is not a third
piece item that I want to clear up loose
ends I'm calling them one the muddy
cards are really useful I get questions
in those that that spark something and
this is a question that came up two or
three times in the muddy cards and I
have an address there and that is you
know we did we were working with rotor
problems and remember this problem
here's our rotor and arm I did it this
way to make some things obvious but this
is z direction it's rotating about that
axis I've got a point mass up here our
hat so this is are actually going to
make it a capital R so it's easier to
distinguish from the r hat and this is Z
and this thing's rotating has got
bearings here
keep it going and we wanted we were
taught we talked about torques so this
is my point a oh I want to write the sum
of the torques about a time derivative
of the angular momentum we've done this
problem before so I'm just putting up a
couple of points for review to clear up
some possible misconceptions Plus this
term so what about point a now in this
problem what's the velocity of point a
zero so again we can get rid of this guy
I'm going to come back to this do an
example one of these days where this
isn't zero where it's really handy it
tells you how to be able to do a problem
where that's not zero okay
this is true
I need a free body diagram of our little
mass so here's my free body diagram and
it has possibly a force in the Z
direction they come from the rod does
rods that's supporting this thing right
it's possibly a force in the Z direction
the force in the R hat direction the R
direction there is a force in the theta
direction going into the board and
there's mg okay all sorts of forces on
this thing and the question was asked
when we did this problem before and did
the time derivatives of the angular
momentum we found that we got there's
three terms that I'll write up down here
for you I'm just I'm just seeing in
advance that we're going to do when you
solve this problem you find out that it
takes torque to accelerate the shaft
spin that's the driving one that's what
makes it happen makes it accelerate we
had two more terms that were torques at
this point that is what it takes to
support this system it's trying to bend
out it's trying to bend back those are
torques that show up here and we
actually get them when we work through
this but we don't get a something that
tells us about the moment the torque
created this point caused by gravity so
why the question was you know why don't
we get the torque about this point
caused by gravity is clearly mg down
there's clearly a moment arm so mg R is
a torque about this point and if you
were doing the statics problem in 2mm
there'd be a torque around this point
caused by the weight of this thing just
sitting there not even spinning okay and
what we're doing here gives you no help
with that but just for a quick district
quick review of this problem more in the
line of helping you think about the quiz
this then is our and we'll call this
point B and this is point a remember
this is our B with respect to a cross P
with respect to O okay and that's where
angular momentum comes from in this
problem that is our R hat plus Z K hat
cross M times the velocity which is our
Omega Z and that must be in the theta
hat direction when you multiply these
out and theta theta hat make a Z is
Theta dot your inner kind of
interchangeable in this problem so when
you multiply this out you get two terms
M R squared theta dot k hat minus
mr z theta dot R hat two terms from this
and when you do the time derivative of
dhdt you get three terms mr squared
theta double dot in the K now why do you
get three terms because this term has to
we're two variables in it that are
functions of time theta dot has a
derivative and our hat has a derivative
because it rotates so one of the key
bits of mathematics you have to kind of
learn in this course so I'm kind of
giving you a little quiz review here is
you need to know how to take the
derivative of a rotating vector and
that's what we do here gives us two
terms - M R Z theta double dot R hat - M
R Z theta dot squared theta hat so three
terms in this time derivative of the
angular momentum and they have to be
equal to the external torques so this is
equal to the summation of the torques
about a the external torques well you'll
need a torque in the K direction that's
what it takes to accelerate the thing
make it go faster this mass has a force
on it to make it go faster that's this F
in the theta hat direction and that rods
haven't push on that mass the mass
pushes back on the rod so if in the
theta directions like that the mass
pushes back on the rod it twists the rod
or tries to
that's a torque about this in the r @
direction so there's centripetal
acceleration it takes force to cause
centripetal acceleration
it's that force is inward it's about a
moment arm Z and so this gives you a
torque about that point a in the theta
direction so these are three different
terms each one has a purpose no work is
done here no work is done here because
there's no movement now but gravity that
we started this thing question is why
doesn't gravity pop out of this because
this only tells you about the time rate
of change of angular momentum and
gravity has nothing to do with angular
momentum R cross P is all that angular
momentum is then the linear momentum of
little pumps of mass times the radius
from the point you're computing the
angular momentum has nothing to do with
G never will so you never get you'll
never get the G static moment G related
static moment out of this equation it's
there though and if you were designing
the system you'd have to take it into
account
so remember I brought it didn't bring it
today but I have my shaker I've bolted
it to the floor inside of that shaker is
a little rotating mass has a little arm
and eccentricity they have some mass
that I'm going to make em rotating theta
direction and it rotates at constant
speed so it's some constant Omega theta
double dot equals zero so I just got my
shaker bolted to the floor it's putting
a lot of vibration into the floor and
the question that someone came up with
on a muddy card that was a really
insightful question why or didn't say
why they said shouldn't the torque
required to drive this thing somehow be
affected by gravity hmm so does the
torque that it takes to run this around
and around depend on gravity what's the
question that was asked so let's take it
kind of take a quick look at that we
just discovered that the hdt doesn't
tell you anything about torque from
gravity okay well let's see what happens
in so the summation of the external
torques now I'll call this now point a
where it's rotating about this point now
doesn't move in this problem so it's an
inertial point I'll mention the torques
with respect to a is d H with respect to
a DT and there's no additional terms
because it doesn't that velocity point
is zero and that's D by DT and the
torque is just our cross P so that is M
e theta dot that's the velocity that's
the momentum
and the I've left out something
so R cross P I need an e squared in here
M e squared theta dot in the K hat
direction
I need to take the time derivative of
that that's a constant that's a constant
that's a constant it's only comes from
this term okay and that gives me m e
squared theta double dot K hat direction
and that's got to be equal to the sum of
the torques in the system the external
torques and what are they well and it's
the torques about this point so axial
forces in this thing contribute no
torques transverse forces external
forces only come from the mg on this
thing so my torques on the system there
is some mechanical torque being applied
that's what I'm looking for
I've got a motor driving this thing so
there's some T of T in there
I'm torque okay minus M G e cosine theta
is the moment arm so there's this force
there's this moment arm is e cosine
theta so this is the external torque
caused by gravity but all of this equals
what what's theta double dot zero okay
external torque is mg e cosine Omega T
theta is Omega T and so indeed as this
thing goes around when it's coming up
you got to apply enough torque they'll
lift it against gravity want to clear as
a top gravity is helping it going down
the other side so in fact if you plotted
the torque is a function time for this
system it's like this
it's just lifting that mass up and down
and of course if there's any friction
in this thing etc is going to have to
apply a little bit of torque for that
too but indeed this is it as an
insightful question that someone asked
is that the gravity does have to have
enter into this thing so there will be a
torque that the motor has to supply to
drive this thing in there in gravity
yeah it's working for Torvalds who have
MD squared of theta double dot is yes II
would if I alive this thing was spinning
up and I was trying to account for the
torque required to spin it up then I
would actually that and here it is I
would then I would include that this
would be the an equation of motion that
says all these things are true and I
could solve for torque again and it
would allow me to decide how fast I
could spin it up right if I have a dinky
little motor doesn't spin up very fast
of it I really powerful motor that can
really put it to it spin up quickly okay
all right
so now I want to move on to the third
topic which is going to go back to where
I left off last time talking about we
need to move on from particles to rigid
bodies so we can do more interesting
problems and so I want it to pick up
with the subject of angular momentum for
rigid bodies now last time I just barely
scratched the surface of this and lots
of muddy card says I don't get it and
expect you to get it with it being
half-baked and the first time we've seen
it so we're going to continue and we
won't finish today so let's think about
a general rigid body here's my inertial
system got a body out here that's
rotating about some point a a could even
be outside the body and have it rotate
about it and attach to a as a reference
frame little X little Y little Z so
there my XY frame now I put up last time
a there's a two page two pages out of
Williams which gives the equations for
the moments and products of inertia in
terms of summations of masses times
particle locations and in order to do
that Williams defines a coordinate
system on this body and that coordinate
system is fixed to the body rotates the
body and Williams calls that coordinate
system little o X Y Z and his in his
book he calls the nurse'll frame big o X
Y Z it's really hard to do that in the
blackboard now you
to tell it apart okay so I'm going to
depart and my frame in here is my is an
a XYZ frame but a and O for reading that
handout are the same thing a and little
o to frame fixed to the body that's
rotating with it we can write angular
momentum for rigid bodies as a vector HX
having a component in the I Direction J
directing these coordinates as the
product of a matrix of the of constants
and these constants are these moments of
inertia and products of inertia terms
and so forth all right add a couple more
of these why why it's a symmetric matrix
and you multiply it by the components of
the rotation that you are rotating this
object so here's a vector Omega this
object is rotating about a the direction
the axle axis of rotation is like that
and you can break this rotation rate
into components in the XYZ system and
that's what these are these are the
components of it
so you multiply out this matrix and a
vector you will get individual equations
for the HX hy and Hz components of the
angular momentum of that object okay
now let's consider let's just do a case
where the spin is only about the z axis
we do lots of these problems the book
has a whole chapter on it they're called
planar motion problems and just
typically pick the spin around the Z as
a convention and if you have a case like
that then H here is I times 0 0 Omega Z
then you multiply that out you get I XZ
omega z iy z omega z n i ZZ omega Z
vector times the square matrix gives you
back a vector that's what you get back
and if you want to write H as a vector
which we frequently do H houses with
respect to a and we'll find I here is
also with respect to a that would be
very careful in in your construction of
this matrix has to do with the point
about which you are computing your
angular momentum ok if you want to write
this as a vector then this becomes H X I
hat plus hy J hat plus HZ k hat this is
where the unit vectors come in when you
are expressed this as a vector you take
these three components and these are H X
hy Hz
the first this little double subscript
the first one tells you the component of
H this is HX hy Hz the second one tells
you the axis of rotation about which the
object is spinning to give you this
piece of angular momentum
so I XZ is HX spinning at rate Omega Z
okay
now the direction of spin was what's the
inter vector in the direction of
rotation for this problem
what's omega is if we can start off with
just direction it's only was it spinning
in the Z direction just spinning just
spinning in the Z direction but I
multiply this thing out I get three
terms and I get term in the I a J and a
K now these two terms this is AI X Z
Omega Z I plus I Y Z Omega Z J plus i ZZ
Omega Z K okay that's these three terms
these two terms exist because I've
assumed that these off diagonal terms
are not zero now the problem we started
with we started with an example left I'm
our bicycle wheel thing with the
unbalanced masses on it we use the
Williams formulas to compute these
different terms
if the off diagonal terms here are not
zero then when you write the angular
momentum expression you get parts of the
angular momentum that are not in the
direction of spin that's that's a really
important conclusion so the off diagonal
terms lead to angular momentum not in
the direction of spin and when you take
the time derivative you end up with
torques and they're just they're right
back through this problem up here so if
if you have off diagonal terms in this
matrix when you spin it around one of
its axes
it is dynamically unbalanced okay so the
author but if these are not zero if you
spin it around one of the axes of the
system for which these are defined in
which these are defined you find out
that
you get unbalanced torques in the system
so those two go together now
so and just another way of saying that
is any time you at this any time you end
up with the angular momentum vector not
pointing in the same direction as the
rotation then the system is going to be
dynamically unbalanced
let's whoops I want this one
actually I kind of want to keep the
Atwoods machine here
so we this was our unbalanced bicycle
wheel problem that we had talked about
last time I can simulate that with this
I've basically I've drawn it like this
so this is the problem now this thing
this thing is definitely is unbalanced
it's trying to do this as it as it goes
around okay and last time we actually
worked up what the from the William
formulas what the moment of inertia
matrix look like so now this X Y Z
system are attached and rotating with
that frame so my axis of spin is
yeah I think this one's a little
exaggerated this one is like this one
that drawing is like this the X like
that so X is like this Z is like that
minus X minus e so when this thing spins
that's the problem that's drawn there
okay and if I compute with those with
Williams formulas the various quantities
so i with respect to a for this system
this the first term the IX X term is
summation M I Y I squared plus Z squared
and so forth you get a bunch of terms
and I will write out one other one here
this term over in the corner is m XZ as
IX e and that's minus summation of the
mi x I Zi and so forth and if we went
through and worked up each of these
things i with respect to a for this
problem comes out M z1 squared 0 minus M
x1 z1 0 minus M x1 z1 the middle term M
x1 squared plus z1 squared 0
zero and M x1 squared so that's what
this mass moment of inertia matrix looks
like for these two particles
so now if I want to write the angular
momentum of this system using this new
notation I would say that it's I
computed respect to a times my Omega and
let's our case is zero zero Omega Z and
if we write that out we do that multiply
that out we end up with a minus mx1 Z 1
Omega Z 0 and M x1 squared Omega Z these
are our three components HX h y HZ
and if you wanted to write it as a
vector and you add the unit vectors so
the HX and the I plus zero for the hy +
H Z in the K so what now if you went and
took the time derivative of those terms
what do you get torques and you'll get
two returns when we do the example of
indigo so what we're doing is not very
different from that you're going to get
the torque that it takes to accelerate
it around the spin axis but you're also
going to get the torque two derivatives
of this one gives you two terms and
these are the moments torques about that
center of the axle in this case trying
to twist the system around okay now
reach some closure here at a good
stopping point
here's our system one last time here's
the z axis the angular momentum that
comes out of this you have a component H
Z in the Z direction and you end up with
a component it's got a minus in it in
the X direction like this so that the
total H vector with respect to a looks
like that and it's not in the direction
of spin it's actually perpendicular to
our bar here okay
and it's dynamically unbalanced so just
to how do we make the transition from
that to rigid bodies the Williams
formulas that are these say that if you
want the mass moment of inertia of a
body all you have to do is sum up all
the little mass bits at their correct
distances off of off of axes and you
will get it so we when you have
particles you can just add them up when
you have a rigid body those summations
become integrals and for example I ZZ is
the integral of why should I say this x
squared plus y squared DM every little
mass bit
alright looks like is there an exam some
distance away I see a lot of people
vanishing okay so let me I'll tell you
what I'll just make it easy for it and
let you go let me just say one thing so
we're we're going for every rigid body
there is a different set of axes for
which when you go to make up this matrix
you can make it diagonal and those are
called the principal axes and that's
where we're going next those play a
really important role in what we want to
do okay